but let's try the seven seven zero area
code caller from seven seven zero what's
going on
hi David is this me that's you hey uh
kind of a big-picture question but where
do you see the Republican Party kind of
moving in a post Trump kind of world I
guess this was kind of you know either
2020 or 2024 but well in 2020 I mean I
think it depends so I think you're right
Lee suggesting that it depends on
whether Trump is reelected in 2020 I
think that there's going to be a bite
within the Republican Party before Trump
you had kind of three wings of the
Republican Party you had the Mitt Romney
low tax pro-business types you had the
more religious conservative types who
focused on issues like abortion and
moral so-called moral issues and then
you have the libertarian types I I guess
we would call them libertarian
conservative wing I believe that in the
post trump era there is going to be a
battle in the immediate and it might be
2020 if Trump loses it might not be
until 2024 which is going to be the
old-style Republican versus the Trump
style Republican and this will be a
really important turning point for the
Republican Party are there are they
going to allow the Trump presidency to
open up the door to that now this is the
type of person that we want representing
us in the Senate in the House of
Representatives as a governor
potentially as a presidential candidate
um or are we going to say that was a
disaster and we are going back to
someone more in the mold of like a
George W Bush type and I think that
that's a fight that could take several
years for the Republican Party to kind
of hash out whenever it is that Trump
leaves the oval office all right thanks
very much David
okay thank you very much appreciate the
phone call